in the opening scene a flight from
berlin is about to land at jfk airport
new york inside a nervous flight
attendant calls his colleague and asks
her to come to the cargo hold area
immediately on her way she asks the
little french girl emma to turn off the
music she then proceeds to another
passenger joan luss and tells her to sit
back in an upright position as the plane
is landing shortly in the back her
terrified fellow attendant informs her
that there is something alive in the
cargo hold even though there are no
animals listed on the manifest confused
the female flight attendant opens the
whole door but sees nothing when
suddenly a shrouded creature breaks
through the door and attacks them in the
following scene the plane is landed on
the runway but the airport officials
don't find any signs of life on it the
210 people on board have gone completely
silent and the plane has switched off
all electronic signals seeing this the
airport in charge bishop immediately
calls several government agencies for
reinforcement mentioning that the
situation is really bad elsewhere we see
an epidemiologist and the head of the
center for disease control named ephraim
attending court mandated custody
counseling afram and his wife kelly are
separated because he prioritizes his
work before family they share custody of
their son zack now sitting in front of a
total stranger kelly chooses to announce
that her boyfriend matt is soon going to
move in with her and zach which ephrem
is not pleased about during the custody
session hefrom's emergency only cell
phone rings repeatedly and as a result
he is forced to interrupt the counseling
session as he receives the call he finds
out about the plane he then calls his
junior nora and tells her that he wants
full control over the investigation soon
ephraim arrives at jfk airport and
greets his colleagues nora and jim
homeland security wants to treat the
incident as a terrorist attack but
ephraim explains to them the possibility
of a virus and how contagion works
eventually because of his speech and his
intimidating carton of milk homeland
security backs down and cdc takes charge
elsewhere in a pawn shop two thugs try
to sell a watch to the owner setrakian
an old man in his 90s while setrachian
leans over to inspect the watch the
thief tries to steal some money through
the plexiglas however cetrakian grabs
his wrist and threatens to cut his vein
with a knife that he has handy the
second thug has a gun but setrakian
forces him to surrender scared of the
old man the thugs run away later when
cetrakian sees the news about the flight
he goes into his basement and brings out
a cane that doubles as a sword he then
brings out a deformed heart stored in a
jar and starts talking to it cetrakian
claims that the enemy has returned and
he is even more dangerous than the last
time following this he makes a small cut
on his finger and drops his blood into
the jar surprisingly little worm-like
tentacles come out of the heart and
start feeding on the blood back at the
airport while ephram and nora suit up
for biohazard and board the plane he
tells her about his court-ordered
custody session nora references her
relationship with ephraim during the
year that he and kelly separated
apparently they had an affair and
ephraim never told kelly because she
filed for divorce before he had a chance
afterward they board the plane and find
everyone dead in their seats without any
signs of struggle or marking at first
sight it seems as if the deaths were
painless on further investigation they
also find evidence of abundant ammonia
but it's not toxic enough to kill anyone
meanwhile ephram kneels down next to the
french girl emma who seems to have
frozen dead in her seat he reports that
her tongue is pale and there's no
frothing or blood just then nora turns
on the uv lights and with this they see
strange patches all over the plane looks
like there was a party in here as they
move towards the back of the plane we
see one of the dead passengers hands
twitch in the next scene the duo reaches
the back and notices the open door to
the cargo hold where the ammonia patches
are everywhere while ephraim observes it
nora moves to the cockpit and discovers
that even the pilots are dead as she
observes one of the pilots he suddenly
wakes up startling the life out of her a
few moments later three passengers a
metal star bolivar joan and a guy named
ansel also reanimate seeing them ephraim
immediately radios for help mentioning
that there are survivors elsewhere at
the stoneheart investment company thomas
eichorst a german man with strange eyes
visits palmer the chairman of stoneheart
group and also one of the world's
richest men while palmer is having
dialysis administered by his head of
security eichorst delivers a message
that the cargo has arrived safely and
all four survivors have been found here
we get to know that palmer and eichorst
know something about the mysterious
deaths of the passengers back at jfk
airport the director of the cdc everett
barnes shows up and supports ephraim's
decision to quarantine the four
survivors later in the q zone nora tries
to talk to one of the survivors joan she
is a high-powered attorney and isn't
cooperative at all following this ephram
and nora talked to the pilot redfern who
doesn't remember anything after landing
while another survivor ansel complains
about hearing some weird noises the rock
star bolivar is concerned about scoring
drugs meanwhile jim calls ephraim after
he finds a giant nine foot tall
coffin-like box that is not listed on
the manifest they lower it to the ground
and open it and find it full of soil
confused by the structure ephraim
immediately asks the officials to take
samples of the soil for testing in the
following scene the airport in charge
bishop is on the phone yelling at
someone in berlin about the coffin-like
box suddenly he hears a strange noise
and begins following it around the cargo
storage area there he finds blood
spilled on the floor and something
pulsing under a cloak as he goes near it
a giant creature rises and extends a
tentacle from its mouth into bishop's
neck sucking all of his blood and
draining him out then it throws him to
the ground and smashes his head before
fleeing that felt a little extra
elsewhere the german eichorst visits a
latino gangster gus and assigns him to
pick up a van with a box from the
airport and deliver it to stoneheart at
first gus refuses claiming that it is a
very dangerous mission however when
eichorst promises to fix his mother's
immigration status and clear his
brother's criminal records he agrees
after this icorst gives him three rules
don't examine the cargo don't make any
stops and make it back to the rendezvous
point by daybreak additionally eichorst
gives gus a black business card that
will grant him access to the airport
amid strict security meanwhile the old
man setrakian arrives at the airport
where all the victims families are
gathered to protest although he is
stopped by the security he fakes a heart
attack and gets close enough to talk to
him about the plane later ephram faces
the victims families on the media
briefing that there are only four
survivors among the 210 passengers and
that they have no explanation for it yet
he also mentions that the dead bodies
can't be handed over to the families due
to the risk of the unknown virus hearing
this the crowd begins to protest and
this one guy even scores a critical hit
slapping his face but ephram assures
them that he will provide answers within
48 hours in the next scene a medical
examiner video calls ephremen nora
showing that the bodies have
non-traumatic incisions on their necks
in addition their body chemistry has
been altered preventing them from
decomposing normally the bodies are also
filled with a white ooze instead of
blood after a while as ephraim and nora
are heading to examine the aircraft
cetrakian who is also present there
suddenly mentions that the corpses must
be beheaded and burnt along with the
giant coffin however jim and ephraim
think that he is crazy they also notice
a sword in the old man's cane and they
have him arrested later that night the
medical guy examines a body under uv
light and discovers strange worm-like
patterns under the skin elsewhere
everyman nora examined the plane's cargo
hold where they find a tiny worm
writhing around and trying to make
contact with their skin they consider it
to be a parasite looking for a host and
put it inside a bottle just then nora
finds a bunch of other worms in a clump
of soil nearby immediately they go to
search for the coffin but find it
missing they then head to the security
room but the cctv cameras show that the
coffin disappeared into thin air when
aphrom asks to pause the footage he
notices a strange entity lifting the
coffin and disappearing off the top of
the frame since the footage is only
seven minutes old effermorter's gym to
seal off the airport and stop to check
all the vehicles that are likely to
carry the coffin because if something
straight up flew away with it it must be
in a car later gus puts on his fake id
and gets in the van with the coffin and
drives off however after only a short
while he is stopped by the police who
ask him to pull over just as he is about
to get exposed jim arrives he then shows
jim the business card that i coursed
gave him and surprisingly jim lets him
go here we get to know that jim is also
working for eichorst and palmer damn
imagine he did frodo dirty like that
dough afterward the medical examiner
removes a deformed heart from a corpse
to his surprise the heart starts to beat
shedding worms one of them gets into the
examiner's hand and he frantically
manages to remove it with a tweezer just
then all the corpses even the dissected
ones rise from their beds and attack him
elsewhere cetrakian has been held
captive in jail over the weekend because
charges have been pressed and there's no
judge to hear the case meanwhile another
inmate notices that cetrakian has a
holocaust tattoo with the number 8230385
back at stoneheart eichorst reports to
the billionaire palmer that everything
went well however he mentions that the
jew aka setrakian is still after
something it appears as if the three
have a history which dates back decades
before leaving he assures palmer that he
will take care of everything the next
morning before dawn gus crosses the
bridge in the van carrying the coffin in
the following scene emma's father
returns home heartbroken and is in shock
to see emma at the door she looks green
and infected saying that she's cold the
father hugs her tight and is relieved
that she is home even in the condition
that she is in later gus arrives at an
underground parking garage when he
doesn't see eichorst around he gets
curious and tries to inspect the coffin
inside the van as he goes near the
coffin it starts growling and thumping
prompting gus to run away from there as
fast as he can
back at jfk airport ephraim nora and jim
find bishop's body with a smashed head
they also discover the same white
discharge and ammonia meanwhile at the
quarantine zone the four survivors
decide to leave the place and go back to
their families although ephraim mentions
that they are still in danger the
quartet doesn't comply with no options
left ephram calls the police who take
charge seeing this joan gets mad and
calls the secretary of health and human
services in no time the secretary calls
ephraim and declares the quarantine
invalid due to lack of evidence to add
to his problems ephraim is even
suspended by his boss at the stoneheart
group palmer and eichorst talk about how
the cdc is hindering their plans it is
revealed that palmer was the one who got
the survivors out using his influence
elsewhere in jail eichorst meets
cetrakian and tells him that the master
is watching cetrakian through him here
we get to know that eichorst was one of
the nazi generals at the concentration
camp where cetrakian a jew was held
before leaving i coursed taunts him
reminding him of his wife's death in the
next scene norah and ephraim meet the
pilot redfearn in a bar and begin to
interrogate him redfearn explains that
the box was loaded onto the plane by
government officials hearing this efrom
is taken aback and he convinces the
pilot to be admitted to the hospital for
an in-depth examination next we see
survivors joan and bolivar at dinner
when they start hearing strange noises
in their heads joan's lips start to
bleed into her wine making her rush
outside at stoneheart palmer's assistant
informs him that he has located a
suitable donor liver palmer thinks he
might not need it anymore but agrees to
the plan as a backup later that day
ephram goes to his wife kelly's house
where she tells him that she's glad he's
on the case ephram finds his son in the
back with matt converting his old office
into a game room surprisingly instead of
being angry he extends a friendly hand
to matt and asks him to keep his family
safe he also encourages zach to be
honest at the custody hearing so that he
can get joint custody in the following
scene bolivar is in bed with three women
when one of the girls runs her hand
through his hair it starts to fall out
soon he fixes on one of the girl's necks
and bites her drawing blood when the
woman panics he kicks everyone out but
he soon starts licking her trail of
blood off the floor at the hospital
ephram and nora look at the pilot under
uv light and find the same incision on
his neck along with the worms crawling
under his skin at the same time emma's
father calls ephraim to thank him for
sending emma home and then hangs up this
stuns the duo and they wonder how a dead
person is alive hence they immediately
head to the morgue to find the truth
elsewhere palmer's assistant drives him
to the parking garage where gus had
delivered the coffin soon eichorst also
joins palmer just as he is about to open
the coffin suddenly the master swoops in
revealing his face to palmer who looks
terrified but happy afterward ephram and
norah arrive at the morgue and find the
front desk chair knocked over and the
phone off the hook the morgue is
ransacked and deserted when the lights
don't work they look around with
flashlights finding all the body bags
empty back at her house emma sits in a
cold tub in the dark her dad notices her
hair is falling out when he leans in a
big tentacle suddenly sprouts out of
emma's mouth and latches onto his neck
killing him
teenagers right in the next scene a
horrible creature without a nose listens
to opera and puts on a rubber nose and
neck to cover his deformities along with
a wig dentures and a thick layer of
makeup turns out that it is eye-coursed
later ephram's colleague jim wonders to
himself what he did by letting the van
with the coffin through hence he calls
someone and argues that afternoon he
goes to the stoneheart group to meet
palmer but eichorst meets him instead
jim threatens to call the police because
of the coffin and the chaos related to
it however eichorst offers a limited
drug trial for jim's wife sylvia who has
a rare kind of cancer and also gives him
an envelope full of money because of the
offers jim backs off meanwhile another
survivor from the plane ansel's
condition deteriorates as his eye
becomes bloodshot his teeth turn into
fangs and he hears a continuous
high-pitched noise when the feeling gets
too overwhelming he goes to the fridge
and takes out a box of raw steak with
blood as he devours it with his new
tentacle tongue his wife catches him in
the act and becomes terrified in the
next scene cetrakian is finally released
and he finds nora waiting for him he
immediately tells her to find the
corpses and burn them but nora hesitates
at the family court effort and kelly
attend a custody hearing for zack upon
being asked by the judge zack says his
dad should see him one or two weekends a
month because he has a very important
job as a result ephram doesn't get joint
custody later ephraim yells at kelly for
taking his son away from him then we're
introduced to a pest control specialist
named vasily he goes to an apartment to
get rid of rats and notices a swarm of
them pouring out of the city's sewers
into the river at cetrakian's pawn shop
a hacker brings him a list of the
plane's passengers beginning with the
first passenger emma setrakian leaves on
his mission to destroy all the corpses
meanwhile bolivar is transitioning
rapidly as his hair falls out his face
turns gray and splotchy and he loses his
genitals that's right in this world
vampire's dicks fall off at the hospital
jim ephrem and nora get the word that
the pilot has disappeared hence they
split up to search the hospital soon jim
finds him in the basement sucking bags
of blood when the pilot tries to attack
him with his tentacle tongue nora
appears so he turns on her as the pilot
is about to attack ephraim arrives in
the neck of time and smashes his head
with a fire extinguisher although the
pilot's head is smashed tiny worms are
oozing out from it nora remembers what
setrakian said about cutting off the
head and burning the body but first
ephram wants to examine it elsewhere
ansel's wife anne-marie takes their kids
to his sister's house and leaves him
alone to rest at home with their dog
when she returns home she finds her dog
dead with its throat and insides ripped
out slowly she goes to the outhouse
which smells disgusting she finds ansel
hiding in the shadows but he suddenly
emerges and snarls at her he's covered
in blood and has chained himself by his
neck so that he doesn't harm her since
the voice in his head forces him to
drink her blood he growls at her to run
somewhere else palmer and eichorst meet
a hacker and ask her to crash the
internet in exchange for a good amount
of money at the hospital nora and
ephraim examine the dead pilot and jim
films them as they cut him open they
find new body systems along with a
six-foot tentacle which they pull out of
the corpse this is one of the craziest
prosthetics i've ever seen this show is
amazing his genitals are also missing
like bolivars and they notice the smell
of ammonia just like on the plane jim
feels guilty and confesses that he let
the van with the coffin go out of the
airport for the sake of his wife's
treatment in a fit of rage ephraim
punches him in the face and leaves soon
after a disappointed nora also leaves
the place with the autopsy footage in
the following scene anne-marie buries
her dog and pushes her arrogant neighbor
into the shed feeding him to ansel
elsewhere gus and his friend felix steal
a mercedes and go to alonso an illegal
car dealer felix has heard that alonso
pays a thousand dollars for the cars but
they end up with only 800 at stoneheart
palmer passes out and when he wakes up
the doctor tells him that they have a
new liver for his transplants next nora
and ephraim go to emma's house and find
her in the basement she immediately
lashes her tentacle tongue at them to
attack as they try to get rid of emma
cetrakian emerges from the shadows and
beheads her with his silver sword bad
ass filch may be a muggle but he doesn't
need a goddamn wand meanwhile emma's
father arrives behind efherman nora
fully turned seeing this cetrakian lops
his head off too he then warns ephram
and norah to stay away from the worms
witnessing the carnage around them
ephram finally agrees with setrakian's
decision to kill the infected however
nora is hesitant and leaves saying there
has to be another way the following
morning at emma's house cetrakian cooks
scrambly eggs and reveals that someone
named the master is an ancient creature
who feeds on the blood of his victims
and turns them the master is a strigoi a
romanian term for a vampire and he is
the one responsible for everything he
let four passengers live so the media
would focus on them and not the dead
giving them time to go home and infect
their families in a flashback to poland
in 1944 cetrakian rides on a train with
his grandmother and brother being taken
to a nazi concentration camp before
reaching the camp cetrakian's
grandmother reminds him of the evils she
told stories about and thinks that
they're going to meet one soon later the
train stops at a camp led by eichorst
soon setrakian and his brother start to
work as carpenters in the camp in the
present joan wakes up in her bed very
sick when her kids bring her breakfast
and hug her she stares at her daughter's
neck for a long time the caretaker finds
it weird and takes the kids away from
her room meanwhile setrakian explains to
ephram that he's going to take down
every passenger from the plane as all of
them have turned next they get to go to
ansel's house setrakian gives ephram a
nail gun with silver nails explaining
that they will weaken the creature
enough for him to get close and kill
them furthermore he discloses that
people who have turned into vampires
come back home for their loved ones and
destroy them in another flashback the
master swoops in at night in the bunkers
of the concentration camp feeding on the
sleeping prisoners when setrachian
witnesses this he becomes terrified and
tells his brother it's the same vampire
from his grandmother's stories and he
needs silver to kill it his brother says
dude we're dealing with nazis here chill
with that silver [ __ ] in the present
nora gets a call about her delusional
mother who wandered away from her
nursing home but they find her the
manager warns nora that they will not
keep her mother at the nursing home if
she wanders off again we're not doing
our jobs and that's your problem
meanwhile ephram and satrakian reach
ansel's house and find that anne-marie
has committed the unthinkable setrakian
holds a silver mirror up to her
explaining that if she's infected it
will vibrate fortunately it doesn't
annemarie has left a note saying where
she has left the kids and that she can't
face the world without ansel after this
the duo walks into the shed and ephram
shoots ansel with the nail gun before
cetrakian beheads him he also destroys
the attacked neighbor who's about to
turn inside the shed the two then burn
the shed and depart for their next
mission meanwhile ephraim leaves nora a
message saying that he wants to get a
quarantine declared because of what he
saw at the stoneheart group palmer wakes
up after his liver transplant and feels
energetic however the doctor warns him
that he won't survive another major
surgery since he has been through many
surgeries in the past back at jones
house the caretaker suggests that jones
see a doctor but she refuses when the
caretaker notices joan's growing eyelids
she packs her things and takes the kids
to her home elsewhere the pest control
specialist vasily is wondering the
reason behind so many rats being led
into the river he opens underground
access and goes into the tunnels as he
walks into the tunnel he finds patches
of ammonia everywhere and hears
something big swoop past him suddenly a
horde of vampires creeps out of the
darkness and approaches him fast scared
and unarmed vasily runs and escapes out
of the tunnel leaving its lid open
surprisingly the vampires are burnt by
the sunlight at the nursing home nora
visits her mother while walking her to
her room they hear people screaming
suddenly nora sees a vampire attacking
one of the residents and quickly hustles
her mother the hell out of there in the
next scene ephraim shows the video of
ansel to everett barnes asking to impose
a quarantine on all the passengers and
their families however barnes refuses
meanwhile jim realizes that the
infection is spreading and warns ephrem
that barnes has footage of ephraim
dragging the pilot's body as jim wants
to correct his mistake he helps ephraim
get out of the building soon after
ephraim takes out his sim card from the
phone so that he can't be tracked before
he escapes he asks jim to get the
quarantine declared the next day we see
eichorst in his vampire form stepping
into his white padded room with a man
chained up no word of a lie this dude is
a friend of mine in real life he reels
the chain and drags the man towards his
feeding altar lunging his tentacle to
feed on him
poor cody meanwhile two fbi agents
arrive at kelly's house looking for
ephraim he sees the agents from across
the street and stays hidden zack watches
the news about his dad being wanted for
questioning just then ephraim runs in
through the back door and hugs his son
he tells kelly that something awful is
happening and asks her to leave the city
with zach immediately however his cuck
matt calls the fbi who soon arrives and
handcuffs ephraim later kelly is mad at
mad and yells at him for interfering in
her family matters elsewhere cetrakian
is on his mission to destroy the
vampires in one of the passengers
basements he encounters several vampires
who attack him however he manages to
climb up the basement into the sunlight
before they can grab him then he burns
the house and escapes in the next scene
nora gets a call from jim informing her
about ephraim's arrest just then the fbi
agents knock at her door realizing that
she is in danger nora packs her bags and
leaves through the back door elsewhere
gus meets eichorst in the tunnel where
the latter assigns him to retrieve the
remains of the pilot's body from the
basement of the hospital and dispose of
them gus refuses and strikes at eichorst
but he is easily overpowered and
forcefully made to do as told later jim
picks up gus and his friend felix and
takes them to the hospital soon they
unload the body bag from the hospital
and dump it in the river before dumping
the body felix gets curious and unzips
the bag to see the pilot's tentacle
meanwhile vasily arrives at his work to
find that his office is deserted and his
colleagues have turned into vampires he
fights them by opening the shades and
letting them burn in the sunlight back
at the fbi headquarters ephraim tells
his colleague about the contagious
outbreak throughout new york city as
expected the fbi agents don't believe
him so ephraim volunteers to take them
to the bodies and show them the proof
elsewhere at kelly's house she drinks
with her close friend diane and tells
her about the fight with matt after
ephraim's arrest diane encourages kelly
to leave the city if she wants today is
the day of the solar eclipse so people
stroll along the streets staring at the
sun with special glasses on the fbi
agents with ephraim are stuck in traffic
from the car ephram notices that the
medical examiner has turned into a
vampire and is attacking people seeing
this both the agents are stunned and
they immediately get out of the car to
subdue the vampire sadly they are
completely useless and the vampire
easily kills them with this ephram is
left alone in the car so he escapes
elsewhere on the streets gus and felix
walk along the chaos trying to save
themselves from being attacked suddenly
a vampire appears and tries to attack
felix gus smashes the vampire's head and
worms slither around getting into
felix's hand they struggle to get rid of
the worm when the police suddenly arrive
and arrest them for killing the vampire
who they think is a normal human in the
final scene ephraim goes to setrakian's
pawn store and says that he is ready to
join him on his mission hearing this
cetrakian takes her from downstairs to
the basement room where ephraim is
surprised to see nora and her mother the
episode ends as the old man mentions
that he has a new plan since both nora
and ephraim are now ready to see what
happens next watch the second part in
series recapped